and on the mound the veteran
mike miner 33 years of age hud out of
chapel hill tennessee
and cottage swings and misses and minor
with a terrific first inning one two
three go the white sox
[Applause]
it's lucas chialito
who has dropped his last three starts
witt goes off to the first pitch and
slams it to left and that ball is going
to make it to the wall
and merrifield we're seeing some early
swings both by chicago and now kansas
city's merrifield ambushes
lucas giolito hey wet
if we can't get peaches and roses can we
get a win a victory
and there is a base hit to right field
whit had to make sure that the right
fielder mendic was unable to make the
catch with nobody out he'll make it only
to third but the royals have a first and
third nobody out situation here in the
bottom of the first
first and third salvador perez against
this pitcher
four hits in 15 advance
that's up the middle
looks like two but it will score a run
and the royals take the early
one-nothing lead they will take the
first inning run
nice going yeah hit it hard
and he chases one down in the dirt
that'll bring up your mean mercedes
here's the 2-0 pitch swung on
into right center field over goes taylor
it will fall for a hit abreu is coming
around to score he was off to the races
your mean mercedes is into third with an
rbi triple the socks have tied it at one
now it's up to garcia to get that
guy in from third
with less than two outs
garcia to center field mercedes from
third will tag taylor ramps up a throw
and mercedes is there an extra base on
the back end for vaughn and a white sox
2-1 lead
a chance for danny mendick
curveball ripped to right field that
goes down the line and here comes andrew
vaughan as danny breaks it down and the
sox'll take a 3-1 lead
0-2 from minor to tim anderson and miner
that was that was a pinata swing from
tim anderson if there are fun-sized
milky ways falling out in kansas city we
know why i love his joy for the game
check swing but it was in there and that
is a strikeout that'll end the inning
but chicago scores three times
on just a couple of hits
[Music]
and a cold strike three for mike miner
to get that second out
here's two on two out to mercedes 3-1
white sox
there's a ball that's fair into the left
field corner
moncado will score easily
grand all around third here he comes
relay throw to the plate save ball got
away from perez it's five to one
and your mean ends up at third again
this time i'm guessing a double
and he's knocked in three today
[Applause]
fastball is lifted to right pretty well
hit mendic
on the warning track he's got it
and that is it for the royals in the
third
sox lead 5-1
here i'm out there at second base and
kind of cool and all my uniforms looking
pretty good today and
[Applause]
there's a called third strike no
pressure
no pressure i'm looking good and
i'm not going to make any errors because
nobody's putting her in play
then a little bit of a mixed bag for
lucas today and again we're
we're picking at nits but
this rotation has been that good as he
strikes out taylor he's only allowed one
run through four
back to back one two three innings it'd
be a beautiful thing
yeah he does goes right after him that's
seven strikeouts for mike miner
drove back up the middle and that's a
base hit so a nice start for the royals
here in the bottom half of inning number
five
[Applause]
second base
time for us to fly
5-1 sucks
got it there
so junis gets the strikeout
white sox to go down on strikes in this
game
andrew vaughn to right field down the
line it goes and this is into the corner
fair ball
vaughn throttles down into second base
it's a two out double and the first sox
hit since mercedes in the third so leori
garcia is going to try and drive him in
and a center base hit
vaughn to third here he comes taylor
won't come home and it's 6-1 socks here
in the sixth inning
well that happened fast
the bases are loaded now michael taylor
is the battery yeah this is where you
make the sox pay
great stop by mankato gets the force at
second a run will score but once again a
well-struck ball and the royals get
robbed of a hit
one two
in the air to center garcia is on it to
make the catch
so the royals had the bases loaded with
one out and they get one
and now at the end of six it's chicago
six and the royals two
ground ball fairball
they'll go three to one to get moncotta
nice play over there by santana second
and third that'll kind of play like a
sacrifice bunt
and now jose abreu comes up with runners
at second and third and one out
ground ball base hit here comes anderson
here comes madrigal
it's now 8-2
[Applause]
lawyer sets and fires the 1-1 pitch it's
driven deep to left vaughn's gonna put a
run on it dives and makes a catch
lopez will score on the sacrifice fly
but andrew vaughn just made the
highlight reel
abreu knocked in a couple with a seventh
inning single
fair ball into the left field corner
moncada on his way to third he's going
to try to score and he will on a double
9-3
[Applause]
[Music]
in the air hamilton
and the white sox have swept the royals
they have now won
10 in a row in this ballpark 13-2
against kansas city since the start
of last year